returning to our top story now the u.n
says its investigation into the killing
of al jazeera journalist shirina bakla
shows the bullet that killed her most
likely belonged to israeli forces let's
take a look at what's happened since
shireen was killed
she was shot dead while reporting from
the janine refugee camp in the occupied
west bank
hours after her death the israeli
government began circulating video
suggesting she was likely shot by a
palestinian fighter well it later
changed that account saying it's
possible its soldiers may have killed
her
palestinian president mahmoud abbas
rejected a proposal for a joint
investigation with israel citing a lack
of trust
israeli forces attacked mourners at a
funeral on may the 13th
israel has yet to make an investigation
into the incident public
the media outlets associated press and
cnn announced their own investigations
which found that ubarakula was likely
killed by israeli fire a palestinian
authority probe found
was deliberately killed by israeli
forces on the same day al jazeera said
it would file a case with the icc
and on june the 9th the palestinian
foreign minister took the results of its
investigation to the icc
al jazeera's senior political analyst
marwan bashara joins us now from london
good to have you with us so marwan this
is quite a significant
development that even the un is weighing
in and saying all the evidence it has
seen points in the direction of israel
yes absolutely certainly the evidence is
building up the proof is building up
clearly whatever israel has claimed from
the outset was not credible it was
simply an attempt at mystifying its role
in the crime
against our colleague but i think what
is new in the yuan report that
i thought was uh quite interesting
though i'm not a forensic investigator
but i think the fact that they said
specifically
several single
seemingly well aimed shots
at our
colleagues
means that there was a bit of a
deliberate attempt
to shoot and kill especially coming from
the side of the israeli unit that is
basically hiding behind
some sort of a steel protection
which means they were not exactly
defending themselves they were aiming
well at those who had press written all
over them
but
single several meaning it wasn't just
sort of a machine gun type thing by
mistake
so clearly we're getting closer to
closer to the idea that this might have
been deliberate
whether it was ordered or not whether
this was targeted assassination or not
as for example some palestinians are now
claiming
that and as far as i'm concerned remains
to be seen but clearly the evidence
against israel and its
occupation forces is building up to be
that one of a deliberate
shooting at our colleague rending her
dead
unfortunately and still not taking
responsibility for the act
marwan there have been precedents in the
past where countries don't want to even
when countries don't want to cooperate
with an international investigation the
un has still be able to get some kind of
international investigation or special
repertoire in place what's the
likelihood that this is going to happen
now with all the mounting evidence
you've been talking about
historically speaking sami as you will
know and as our viewers around perhaps
our viewers around the world remember
israel has always rejected
any sort overall for the u.n
even in diplomacy let alone in sort of
what it sees as infringement in its own
uh internal uh investigations or affairs
or permissions or what have you the
israelis have always rejected the yuan
rule they are afraid of what the un
might look in and see
and that's why
they typically resorted to the united
states
unfortunately the united states is not
putting enough pressure at the u.n
and israel
to make sure that this happens
in as far as we can see sami the united
states remains
um you know quite
i don't want to say he hasn't that it's
worse than hesitant it's it's almost
complicit
with the israeli crime in the way that
they continue to defend israel and say
we don't know who's behind it even
though cnn new york times washington
post all the main
media outlets in the united states have
already came up with their editorials
about the matter
clearly for washington it is not about
the act sammy it's more about the actor
if the actor happens to be russian
killing ukrainian journalists
no one is asking for an investigation if
the actor is iranian even if the actor
is palestinian the united states does
not ask for investigations or
commissions but when the actor is israel
it doesn't matter if it's that sort of
terrorism state-sponsored terrorism on
the part of the israeli military then
the united states only and simply ask
for investigation and this is the
dilemma we're in israel would not the
budge do its own investigation of its
own military and it's certainly capable
of doing so the united states would not
put pressure and the un
simply could you know make the claims
but would not be able to get involved
and that was our senior political
analyst marwan bashar there